hello today we're going to look at Mixr
of experts this model has been out for a
while it has there's been blog posts and
so on but this is the paper about the
mixol 8x7 B mixt of expert model uh that
is built on the mistl 7B architecture
and obviously released by mistl Ai and
you can see we are going back to the
good old days of word art uh I like it
but it does take some getting used to
the paper goes by a different name
that's the nickname I gave it which is
don't say data and you'll see that the
entire paper goes without ever telling
you even the slightest hint about where
the training data came from now this I
believe is a smart choice because uh the
let's say fashion dour of the
professional complainer group that's
around ISS to complain about where the
training data comes from and lawsuits
are being filed about copyright on
training data and blah blah blah it used
to be different things it used to be all
the biases of the models and then it
used to be all the crowd workers or
something the the trend let's say on in
Vogue uh with the professional
complainers is to complain about where
the data comes from so Mist doesn't say
anything which I guess is smart but it's
also a little bit weird in a research
paper that is kind of supposed to tell
the research Community how you did stuff
and how they can reproduce it so uh yeah
I don't know if you don't know Mr AI is
a new startup uh I believe out of France
and their approach so far is the most
open source approach of all the AI
startups out there including
uh stability AI to some degree which
Prides itself on being very open source
the mistol models are released under the
Apache License which means is do
whatever you want uh although the flip
side to this is as I already said they
don't tell you where the data comes from
whereas I believe the um stability AI
does tell you at least to some degree
where the data comes from uh and how
they obtained it yet their models are
are released under sort of these uh
Stupid licenses that have usage
restrictions in any
case this paper there's not too much of
surprises in here uh you'll see they
they say well this is a Transformer with
a mixture of experts architecture so I
think it's an opportunity to look at
what that actually means I've made
videos in the past on mixture of experts
expert routing and so on but we can dive
into that here again again and just see
how it's done so mixol 8
x7b is a sparse mixture of experts model
with open weights under Apachi 2 it
outperforms llama 270b and gbt 3.5 on
most benchmarks now what is special
about this is that if you can this right
here is the total parameter count of the
model so and there is a reason they
don't just say well it's uh 56 billion
parameters
I don't actually think it's 56 it's
probably less no um we'll get to that so
it's total parameter count is less than
for example llama 2 now GPT 3.5 we don't
know GPT 3 was 175 it's quite
conceivable 3.5 was a distilled version
of that but it is safe to assume that
this Mixr model has less total
parameters than these models and
therefore it's quite cool to see that it
does outperform these models on various
benchmarks the other thing here and why
they write it like this is that they do
have this mixture of experts this expert
routing in there which essentially means
that for every token it only uses a
subset of its parameters so as a as a
forward signal goes through the network
not every single part of the network is
even used is even activated for that
forward signal and therefore the actual
parameter count that's used per token is
even less which allows for some
optimizations you can do either by being
faster or by achieving higher throughput
so they say here faster inference speed
at low batch sizes and higher throughput
at large batch
sizes it's a decoder only model and the
feat forward blocks picks from a set of
eight distinct groups of parameters as I
said we'll look into that briefly what
that means there's a
32,000 token window context size which
is also on par with other current
Transformer based large language
models it is huge like it's a big is a
big context window um and here is our
first hint according to the where the
training data comes from it is Prett
pre-trained with multilingual
data that's it it's pre-trained with
multilingual data
so they could literally take I don't
know the pile that's multilingual data
they could
take Shakespeare and just add one German
phrase to it we we don't know and uh
they don't say so what is a mixture of
experts model usually in Transformers we
talk a lot about tension the attention
mechanism and so on as being kind of the
core ingredient of these Transformer
models but in fact Transformer models
and Transformer Transformer models are
essentially you have sort of your input
tokens here every token gets turned into
a vector by an embedding embedding layer
then at the very top you have sort of an
out output which is just kind of an
inverted embedding layer so this let's
call it embedding 1 that so you have
output vectors and and and they'll be
turned into uh into tokens again or if
you do next token prediction you just
have one at the very end right here
that's then predicted into one of 32,000
tokens or something like this in the
middle here you have these Transformer
blocks and they'll be repeated I don't
know nend times every Transformer block
this has evolved a bit through the
through the years let's say but
Transformer blocks are usually stacking
on top two different core layers you
know you which are the attention layer
and the feet forward layer so this will
literally be some sort of attention
layer and then some sort of feet forward
uh layer or feet forward network uh what
is is also called as I said usually when
we talk about Transformers we talk a lot
about the attention layer what happens
in the attention layer is that if you
have a sequence of tokens that's being
input the what the attention layer can
do is it can share pass information
around so you want to transform this
signal into the next signal so you get
the same amount of vectors again and the
attention layer allows you to sort of
pass information between any of these
via the attention mechanism right the
next layer that comes so this is a
tension the next layer is the feet
forward Network and the feet forward
network is different the feed forward
Network applies to every single token or
every single output Vector whatever you
want to call it here so if you have a
sentence with different tokens and these
would be the intermediate
representations of them every single one
goes through this network by itself um
so this is a function that applies
individually to each token so this this
here will be some sort of a vector right
and it will go through a feet forward
Network and that could be for example uh
to a dense layer followed by some
nonlinearity followed by another dense
layer so this will go through here and
produce the next
representation and the next token will
go through the same right this token
here will go through the same network
and produce that representation and and
then to have another color this one will
go through the same one and produce this
one right so the feat forward Network
applies individually to each of the
tokens and a lot of parameters are
actually here so all the talk about the
attention mechanism is important because
that's how the individual tokens
exchange information and you make
computation context dependent right
otherwise it's just literally just a bag
of words model
uh however while attention is very
interesting when you talk about context
length and so on memory requirements for
forward passes a ton of parameters are
actually in these feet forward networks
because these feet forward networks
essentially they take in a vector of a
token and they multiply it by a giant
weight Matrix so the this Vector here
the hidden Dimension I think they have
it somewhere detailed here so the hidden
Dimension or the dimension ality of
embeddings will be like 4,000 and then
the hidden Dimension if I see this
correctly will be 14,000 if I interpret
this correctly that means that this
thing here will be 4,000 Dimensions so
every single token will be a vector of
4,000 Dimension and then this here will
be um sorry blowing that Dimension up 4K
to uh what was it
14k then there will be a nonlinear 30
then it will be another one going 14
sorry going
14k K to
4K and then it it will go on so
14,000 * 4,000 that's already like 50
million parameters or something in a
single one of the these matrices so
these are big chunky things um and it
also means since there is only one per
block or well if you repeat these there
two per block but since there's only one
per block it means that you have to
treat every single token the same right
every single token goes through this
weight Matrix and then through this
weight Matrix therefore the
transformation is the same for every
single token and that is what mixture of
experts aims to change mixture of
experts essentially says hey wait a
second what if we not only had one of
these but multiple ones right right so
there's this these are the w1s then we
have the
W2s then we have the
w3s and so on now we can make the
individual ones smaller right if we want
if we still want to retain the same
parameter count we're free to do that
but the main part is that if I now have
a vector here I
can put it push it through each of these
functions individually and then combine
their output at the end right now why
would I do that um if you just do it
like this you distribute you compute you
gather again there might already be some
Advantage notably we know that from
multi-head attention right the attention
layer is also has been split up like
this so every attention layer will have
multiple attention heads which collect
different signals uh and then they'll be
gathered together again so there could
be already advantages due to that
however this paper goes further they say
we'll do a sparse mixture of experts so
instead of sending it to each of these
computation paths and we'll call these
these here will be the
experts um so this there'll be expert
one expert 2 expert 3 instead of sending
it to each of those experts we only send
it to a subset of experts uh so how
about we only send it to one expert so
this token goes here right uh but then
the green token for some reason will
send here and so two tokens Can Go
different ways now what decides where
each token goes that will be another
small so-called routing neural network
they'll call that g a routing neural
network will decide where a particular
token goes to which expert a particular
token should be routed in in fact they
always select two experts and I believe
we've talked about this in the papers on
like gard and things like this that
there are stability reasons why you
would want to Route the same token to at
least two experts uh so if you want you
can go watch that video on mixture of
experts routing on sparse mixture of
experts routing but in any case the G is
just another neural network remember
what we're doing is we are taking the
intermediate vector representation of a
single token and we'll try to decide to
which of the fixed size expert or of
which of the expert out of a fixed set
of experts this particular token goes so
that's like a classic classification
problem right so I have a have my
feature Vector X which is a vector and I
push it through some sort of a function
and that gives me one of I don't know
and different class labels or outputs or
logits right so
um and then I can just take the highest
one or the highest two and then route my
token there and if these are logits they
even give me they even give me let's say
this is big this is small after I
exponent after I soft Max my log it soft
Max my logit I'll get some sort of a
distribution here or at least a waiting
and so I can see ah okay a lot of this
this expert and a little bit of that one
so let me send it to these two experts
gather their signal and
then collect the output according to
these weightings right so I'll do a
weighted sum at the end depending on
what this function told me how I should
route this particular token for the next
token you're going to do the exact same
thing and this F function will tell will
give you some different outputs some
different weightings of expert so not
only only is the signal different that
you pass through this layer but the path
the computation
takes is different for each signal
and the routing itself is also
determined by the signal so you'll
notice the same X that is being routed
through the computation over here is
also used to decide where it should be
routed in the first place it's a bit
like I don't know you you get you got
people to distribute to different jobs
and you you look at them and you'll be
like well you're very tall you go do the
thing where you need to reach high
shelves right and then that person goes
goes there and does that job um so the
person itself is used to decide where
the person goes and then the person does
something else than all the other person
do that's I don't have better way to
explain that so the the F here it will
also be like a small neuron Network that
decides where stuff goes ultimately if
you look at this in terms of uh mathy
math you'll see if x here is the
intermediate representation in a given
layer of a given token you'll see that
we put it through the routing Network
and through the expert Network and then
at the end we'll build a weighted uh a
weighted sum according to what the
router said um and what the expert
output now obviously the trick is that
if this routing function outputs
something sparse um for example if you
build it like this if you have this top
K in here the output will be sparse
which means it will be zero for most of
the experts you don't even have to
compute a lot of these experts and
that's the whole trick that's how you
save on computation um and make the
active parameter count for each token a
lot smaller and have different tokens
use different experts notably I don't
see any sort of entropy regularization
or so that would kind of guarantee that
different things different tokens are
getting routed to different experts I
guess it's just not necessary but I do
believe that some of the uh initial
mixture of experts papers did have such
terms in their loss but if it's not
necessary I guess that's fine too um um
the other thing here so they
say uh EI denotes the output of the I of
expert okay so I are the number of
experts and they go to N I guess they're
n experts and then here GX subi denotes
the N dimensional output of the gating
Network for the if of
expert this I believe is a mistake in
the
paper um
um maybe not but so if you think of
it if like this thing here outputs a
vector right uh and you ultimately sum
these vectors and you want another
Vector than these things here they must
either be scalers or matrices but they
cannot be like n
dimensional the output of the gating
Network for the if expert cannot be n
dimensional so I believe what they meant
to say is that g of X has an N
dimensional output and then GX of sub I
is the ith entry of that end dimensional
output which this n dimensional output
is just the what I said before this kind
of classification layer where you only
take the top K in their case the top two
entries before so you set everything
else to zero uh and then you normalize
that using a a soft
Max um and I I believe what they say
here so the neural network is just a
linear linear feed forward layer uh so I
I I think that is correct because if x
is a vector this is a matrix you'll get
a vector you get the vector is hopefully
n dimensional you get two and so so
small mistake I was quite confused when
I read it but I do believe the paper is
bit wrong um yeah they make a
distinction here and they say hey okay
if since we're doing this kind of
routing and since we have this sparse
element in there we should distinguish
between the model's total parameter
count which is also the so-called sparse
parameter count which grows with n
obviously as you add experts you add
parameters because as you have more and
more and more of these computation paths
and each one has their own um weight
matrixes or
matrices uh note still like don't don't
be
confused we're still so there is a
function
FF let's let's call it FF but it's no
longer called FF but there is a function
FF and we apply it to each token
individually right individually which
means that every single token goes
through the same function in here right
and that function is always the same
function so that hasn't changed what has
changed is that internally inside of
these functions if you peer in then the
input X might take a different
path than the input y so the input y
might might take a different computation
path in here and activate different
parameters inside of this but it's still
the case each token is pushed separately
through that feat forward stage it's
just that inside of that feed forward
stage we have some sparse elements and
depending on the signal that we put in
there depending on the token gets routed
differently they say yeah so the the
other thing is the active parameter
count um which is the number of
parameters used for processing an
individual token which grows with k so
the more experts you consider per token
the more obviously work you do so the
the trick here is to only use two out of
the eight experts for each token which
immediately divides the number of active
the number of parameters per token
inside of these feet forward layers by
four uh they also say that this can be
used to do expert parallelism now expert
parallelism if you're doing really high
throughput stuff you put each of those
experts like this is
W1 uh this is W2 this is W3 so there
might be two matrices here and there
might be some nonlinearities whatnot but
you put each of these experts onto
different gpus so just GPU 1 this gpu2
and so on and therefore to each GPU it
looks like a dense operation and it's
just that the the router here decides to
which GPU you send the to token this
obviously only works if you have a high
throughput right if you kind of pipeline
your signals and then you have maybe a
bit of queueing here and some
coordination and so on or very high
batch sizes and so on but um if you have
that throughput then you can Shard the
model like this so every expert to a GPU
and then for each GPU individually it no
longer looks like a sparse operation
right for each GPU individually it looks
like a dense operation and obviously
gpus are very good at dense
operations um so you can massively speed
up the throughput like assume assume
these were regular feet forward layer
and you just do model
parallelism this would also be a dense
operation per GPU but every GPU would
have to kind of treat every token or
essentially every token goes everywhere
if you're not doing a sparse mixture of
experts so that's how you achieve higher
throughput uh by
if you
have 3,000 token you only you only go
2,000 go here 2,000 go here and 2,000 go
here because you have two experts per
token whereas if you doing fully fully
feed forward Network it would be 3,000
token 3,000 token and 3,000 token per
expert per expert let's say uh so that's
how you increase through put with spur
good uh this is all of machine learning
has come down to this right here that
that's the magic uh which essentially
just says this is the the the the new
feet forward layer which essentially
just says okay there is routing we'll
take the top two uh we'll make the soft
Max over the top two and that is going
to be our waiting for how we actually
aggregate what is the the old the all
the classic feed forward network of a
classic Transformer and that's
it results I don't want to go too much
into results and I find experimental
results are obviously interesting if you
actually want to compare different
things but in this case they do just
keep on par or outperform these other
models such as the Llama 270 billion
parameter model and also uh chat chat
GPT so G PT
3.5 um you you can it depends a bit so
these plots you know always be careful
so here they say active parameters right
and they compare to like mistol 7B to to
their mixture of experts and the red one
here is llama 2 it's a it's a tiny bit
deceptive obviously it is correct uh the
active parameters for each token are
different and and that determines how
fast you can do a forward pass at
inference time however
however they're not always the same
active parameters right so the increased
performance here it comes from the fact
that D is dynamically decided which
parameters belong to the active
parameter set for each token and and
therefore these plots they're they're
still they're very good obviously but
you have to keep that in mind when you
compare it to a model such as llama 2
which does not do a selection of active
parameters where it's just like all the
parameters are always the active
parameters yeah so yada yada yada
reasoning retrieval so they show that it
can kind of retrieve this this p in this
P key task that is going to be it's a
task where you have to retrieve
something from the context window
depending on where it is they show it
can retrieve it everywhere which I do
find it's a good Benchmark to compare to
others who haven't passed it but
honestly
if if everything is green The Benchmark
ceases to be useful no like make it
harder like show me where this
breaks yeah in any case they also show
that across their context length that
they train with their perplexity does
decrease on a test set and that
essentially means that it can still make
use of the context size so what would be
bad is If This Were to go up again which
would essentially mean that as you add
stuff into the context even though you
can technically uh you're just making
things more noisy but that doesn't
happen so that's good to see but what's
also fairly obvious from this plot is
that the biggest gain you do have uh in
the first few things that you add to to
the context and that's noteworthy
because it still means that it's a it's
a better Strate if if you can smartly
select what you put into the context it
is a much better strategy than just
throwing everything you have into the
context um so for for this particular
task we see it doesn't hurt to put a lot
of more stuff into the context but I
would argue just from
experience very often it is probably
going to hurt to put more stuff into the
context um so keep that in mind and
still try to think of how can you
smartly select what goes into context
bias benchmarks who cares
maybe I guess maybe the European Union
or something they're they're they're
about three years behind everyone else's
Collective Consciousness so they'll
probably make some regulations according
to to bias and they say
they do supervised fine tring so after
pre-training on multilingual data they
do supervised fine training on an
instruction data set wow an instruction
data set followed by direct preference
optimization on hold your horses a
paired feedback data
set yeah yep no no I can I can totally
go out and reproduce this that that this
is this is so informative
um yeah so I guess double-edged sword
right we are all super happy that they
they do this they release the models
they release the models under aachi
which I think not only is it open source
like it's a huge service to the
community because
because they released this under Apache
and nothing has happened the world is
still here it's not burning people
aren't smashing I mean some in some
places people aren't significantly
smashing in each other's head more than
if this model had been released under
some stupid open rail license right I
think that service to the to the Comm
commun that's the biggest service to the
community to show look we can release
something fully freely and nothing bad's
going to happen or at least
nothing worse than had we not released
it uh in the first place or had we
released it under some some dumb license
so super duper duper thankful for that
that is extremely commendable however
you can also definitely see where they
think their let's say business value
comes from or their business risk I'm
not sure which one right here but they
clearly don't say a slightest tone about
the data set this was trained on
um maybe it's just to maybe it's just to
to troll troll the
complainers they could be cool enough to
do that um maybe it's just like maybe
it's just the pile uh like super obvious
but they don't say it just so everyone
of the of the complainer Crowd Goes
Like and then after six months they be
like oh yeah it's just a
pile
all right uh this is pretty cool they do
an analysis of the routings obviously
given that you route different tokens to
these different experts can you somehow
determine do the experts specialize in
different sub kind of obvious sub Fields
they say surprisingly we do not observe
obvious patterns in the assignments of
expert based on the topic the only big
thing they notice is that consecutive
tokens are often assigned to the same
experts plus some some regularities such
as okay all the in like python code all
the leading tokens all the whitespace
tokens are out to the same experts but
other than that there doesn't seem to be
a super obvious pattern um now this
could mean two things it could mean
that uh there there isn't really
semantic patterns it may be more about
different different things uh so
different uh aspects of the tokens that
are important for routing or second that
the the pattern that are patterns that
are considered are so over our heads in
terms of understanding them that we just
can't make sense out of them both are
absolutely possible it's probably a
mixture of both um so usually if if it
goes away from the narrow slice of human
semantics then uh humans have a hard
time understanding it even though it
could be a a patter that's kind of on
the similar level of obviousness as oh
every every uh integer variable is being
routed here and every assignment
character is routed here and and so on
um
but yeah maybe we'll maybe eventually
we'll find regularities or maybe we
won't that's still loud but it's cool
that they've investigated and they have
some more in the some more analysis in
the appendix in case you're interested
in that and that was pretty much it for
this paper as I said we're all I think
it's super cool they just do this and
and they just release it on Apachi so it
means that a lot of people can build
things can build uh new cool
applications and so on um not saying
where the data is from I believe is not
very scientific but Al ultimately
probably smart and uh either yeah
because of incoming regulation or
because it's actually their their kind
of business Val their value as a
business I don't know but but it's
probably a smart idea and yeah let me
know what what you think and let me know
what the best applications so far are of
of Mixr um it's it's really cool and
excited to see how the world goes
forward with more and more open source a
that's it for me thank you for listening
I'll see you around bye-bye